on this episode India turns into the
professor
this is
ask Gary B
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 2 to 2 of the ask
gary vee show beautiful day in New York
City dunk is a periscoping oh he's
double fisted I like that doing
something else and India has transformed
into an elderly not elderly by linnaeus
standards an older gentleman from Europe
true why don't you tell the Vayner
nation who you are what you're doing
here for the week and then a little bit
about yourself I'm Nicolas Mir he's
social media first not not me them and I
actually find find your take of
education quite refreshing you're not
the biggest fan honestly but I thought I
would get a cold shower of reality this
week so thank you for the internship
opportunity the reverse internship
learning the real world at vaynermedia
to see what kind of world my students
get into it's great out and so you know
we've known each other for a nice little
while now where do you teach I think
maybe if I think like Chapman University
of Southern California which is good
private collagen that we put out MBA
students and undergrads hopefully to
vaynermedia and other places in the
world also it's great to have you how's
it going take our house Andy and Andy's
show Andy this is a it's a mean-looking
he's a tough guy yeah I wouldn't want to
work for him I'm glad that he works for
me he has to work sort in state versus a
Tuesday - so yes sure was the first day
yeah so what's your what's your first 36
hour observation of a vein you know
obviously it's a new fancy obviously
your timing was great yeah did you tell
you that on purpose is that perfect I'm
very impressed people are really looking
like they fit in and they're really
focused and everyone is talking about
musically so I started to musically
account yesterday and my twelve-year-old
daughters always come over
I love it and it seems to be people are
really taking this job seriously but
they seems
work for the passion that seemed to be
motivated intrinsically great well
appreciate alright let's get into the
show good to see everybody I'm really
looking forward to the fall I'm not I'm
trying not to travel as much in
September so hopefully we'll get into a
great cadence after Labor Day one thing
you guys should know just for general
content purposes starting middle next
week I'm taking good two-and-a-half
weeks with the family so we'll be very
quiet they'll be a lot of deejaying
content Andy we can finally find all
those little short video clips that are
deeply entrenched somewhere
I feel like dunk should watch every hour
of raw footage of every day levy so it's
60 by then times about eight hours each
yeah I mean you know 480 hours worth of
raw footage of just me alright let's do
it the first question who's asking it
okay this is Parsa what do you think
about using snapchat as a way to sell
and buy products with snapcash would
that be snapchats next big move of
course I think it's an interesting
thought obviously a lot of people in the
US and Europe entrepreneur scene are
affected by we chats unbelievable
success and not only being a Content and
a communication but a retail platform in
in China I think snapcash is something
that snapchat is deep prioritizing I
think on the flip side I think we're
gonna see a lot more commerce coming
from Facebook
I predict that a lot of you will be
selling a ton of stuff through Facebook
24 months from today and so I think
Parsa for snapchat I'm not sure I think
that they're internally I'm sure they're
thinking about the roadmap I'm curious
to think and about what they're thinking
about Instagram stories do they feel
like you know one of the observations
that I'm kind of leaning towards is I
don't think Instagram stories kills
snapchat but I definitely think it may
slow down the migration of thirty five
to fifty five year olds over to the
platform if they can use Instagram to
feed that kind of storytelling so how
are they thinking about that but I think
I was bullish and excited about snapcash
I thought it was a good move by them to
do that way back when I think it's
something you can consider my intuition
is what you're trying to accomplish ends
up becoming a big
within Facebook in the next 24 months
awesome Ted learning the ropes Ted has a
video question let's do it what's going
on Gary
big fan my name is Ted barrage and I'm a
13 year old graphic designer from the UK
so I recently started my design company
and I'm presenting it on Instagram
Twitter snapchat and just about to start
youtube so I'm proud of being a 13 year
old designer and I think I can use that
as a growth hack to make myself better
known out there but some clients when
they find out that I'm 13
take that back as a negative without
actually seeing my work and knowing the
full story so how would you recommend me
going around presenting myself and my
business as a 13 year old designer
Cheers Gary cheers mate Teddy listen I
think you're all excited upfront of like
I'm gonna differentiate myself by being
13 and then you're like but some clients
don't like it of course you're 13 like
literally Andy has like sneakers older
than you right I mean like this is
unbelievable and your composure and your
charisma on the video you're gonna be
very successful I have a funny feeling
at whatever you decided to say when I
met dunk we met in a hotel room I'm like
I mean like I'm like you're coming to
America like some young kids just have
it you know I could tell way more
because I spent more time with him to
know if that he did have it I'm not sure
about you that's a good first impression
for me getting on this show at all but
here's the reality my friend Ted you
gonna learn this at 13 minutes at 16 and
earnest and 19 you're gonna learn this
at 27 you're gonna learn it at forty
held in 53 look great you know learning
at 53 as I'm sure you know what I'm
about to say is true you got to take the
good with the bad
you got to take the good with the bad
for everybody who's gonna give you
notoriety or write an article about you
or actually use you cuz you're 13
there's gonna be people that don't for
everybody that loves that I keep it real
and authentic there's plenty of people
that don't want to work with me because
I curse or because I push against the
traditional system did they like it yeah
hence they did you're right but the
punchline is very simple which is this
Teddy like
you need to be you don't you know don't
hide that you're 13 because you think
you'll make more money you're 13 and and
if you've got real talent that's gonna
serve you extremely well and so I think
the reality is how would I play it by
just being you and doing your thing and
not dwelling on the negatives and not
getting too big-headed about the
positives don't get too upset when
somebody cancels in order when they
found out you're 13 and don't think
you're hot [ __ ] just because somebody
wrote some cool business insider
headline that says 13 year old stuns
with his graphical design skills thank
you for you okay
Chris asks if the Jets win the Super
Bowl before you buy the team will you is
interest so I've been really scared this
question this isn't actually a true
story I did not want this question to be
asked because the truth is I don't know
let's start there I love time looking
into yonder trying to find my future
self basically I'm looking outside right
now and I'm like picturing myself
jumping over a fence and running on the
field and like tackling Brandon Marshall
and getting arrested um I don't think
I'll want to buy them not only that I
got something scarier I don't know if
I'm gonna care about them at all I'm I'm
telling you Ken skelp oh if you're
watching right now please leave a
comment Ken skeltal will tell you that
15 year old me in 1992 at northern in
high school was a bigger New York Ranger
fan than a New York Jets fan and that is
the hidden story of who I am I always
wanted to buy jets so that's kind of
interesting so football was my true
favorite sport but the Jets
weren't good and so you lose steam and
the Rangers were making their march to
my first championship that was one right
there one of the great moments of my
life and and I think that I think here's
what I can tell you if the Jets win the
Super Bowl this year three years from
now six years from now before I get a
chance to buy them or win the Super Bowl
there is a significant chance that all
of my sports energy will be deployed
aggressively towards New York Knicks
because they would be my last team that
hasn't won and there they've already got
a big part of my attention they just
have been so bad for 15 years its
siphoned any excitement out of my body
but I I'm very I'm very concerned about
this question it's actually the scariest
question besides the things I care about
which are the health of my family it's
one of the weird scariest things in my
life I do not want the Jets deep down I
don't think I want the Jets to win the
Superbowl
ya know of our goalie mr. Lundquist
alright alright
Gus Gus asks which pro athlete or
celebrity is the most marketable but it
isn't monetizing it yet well that's a
good question who's the most monetizable
celebrity or athlete right now who's
under monetizing okay so I don't know
the answer because I don't really dig
too deep into that world I mean I know
but I don't know and I don't like
talking about things I don't know but
I'm gonna give a very smart answer I
believe on looks and charisma it is
somebody who's an athlete that is not a
star player so what I mean by that is I
believe that oh look kris humphries
right
he's a very solid gutsy rebounding NBA
player but he became dramatically more
famous and could monetize because Kim
Kardashian and him dated I actually got
married for four minutes so I think that
that's a good comp I think that there's
a stunningly handsome or beautiful man
or woman who's an athlete who's not the
star of their team who either is
gorgeous and can play the modeling role
along with athlete though that doesn't
play out because sports a lot of times
they'll rag on you that you're just
pretty and you can't get it done on the
field
I actually think as I'm talking this
through it's the most charismatic so
what do I mean by that I believe that if
somebody started vlogging Casey nice
nice that case style right now in the
NBA as the ninth man off the bench was a
great guy had a little charisma was a
great storyteller knew how not to blow
up the spot of his fellow athletes
showed the real life of being on a bus
before the game with fans his own life
his crazy brother his awesome mom I
think that there that is the person
right now the most charismatic
storyteller that could be doing it with
a phone that happens to not be the best
player on the team has the most
storytelling capabilities that hasn't
been deployed yet Gilbert Arenas to this
Gilbert Arenas was a very nice
up-and-coming NBA player who then had
some big-time seasons who's the first
guy to blog and use myspace way back
when and became much more famous than he
actually was
and God got better endorsement deals
because of it so that's what I would say
it's really anybody who's an a it's
anybody who's a B or C list celebrity or
athlete that needs to act like me or
Casey or like or like Nash Grier or like
musically stars they need to do the
internet thing while they're on the
mainstream plateau you ask yes very
there's a very big moment professor is
chemically professor professor because
put up a big print if I'm a little
editing for you this is a question yes
okay forced him to go teaching for a
semester and then I would be a pumped as
long as everybody else couldn't run
businesses either if I was just picked
on I'd be pissed that sounds more like
communism so hey if everybody was I'd be
happy it's the same way I feel about the
last two weeks of August do you know why
I'm comfortably taking off for last two
weeks of August because most people take
the last two weeks of August and I know
there's not gonna be as much
productivity and so I'm not falling too
far behind I if I had a teach a semester
what's the question how would you
structure and teach social media
marketing so I would probably if I was
allowed to on a university level I
probably would be and if and obviously
take out the economics could be afford
to I would try to get them out of the
room is out of the classroom as much as
possible whether physically or mentally
and what I mean by that is mentally we
would be in our apps
doing creating I would get the kids out
of if I was in Chapman California I
would go to local businesses I would
take the 29 kids in class
we'd go to lose pizza shop I mean like
Lou we're here and we're here to work
what do you need and I would much
believe I'm so proud of you I'm so
thankful that you reached out to me and
you're taking us up on this week because
you're gonna go be a better you're gonna
go back to school
and what you're gonna learn this week
you're gonna be better because it's real
this is real and the classroom is less
real it's less of the market it just is
and so my answer to your question is I
would force them to do real [ __ ] you
know like I you know I would just try to
get them to do as much real stuff as
much as possible like you can pump you
can watch Gary Vee videos you can read
books you can pontificate you can debate
but nothing beats getting thrown out
like now I can't eat I can tell kids
about swimming okay so what you want to
do it right I can tell you we can debate
what the best stroke is but how are you
gonna be good swimmer you gonna throw
that kid in the pool and so I would put
the kids in as many real-life situations
as possible
and I would do it in a couple different
ways one I would try to use my
connections if I was allowed to based on
this fantasy world you've created and
get them to go to like Under Armour or a
Toyota see how they think about it but
then I'd also do a competition the last
three weeks of the semester I would say
okay we're all gonna go to the farmers
market you all have three weeks to
figure out what you're gonna sell in a
farmers market and then all you can use
this digital for the whole three weeks
leading up to it and then and then
whoever sells the most fruit wins and so
like try to get them into that kind of
mentality because I think that matters
I'm very scared professor of
eighth-place trophies I'm very scared of
rewarding people for success that isn't
real we would have the fruit and
vegetable farmers market competition and
then the next day in class I would say
unbelievable job Sally and I would say
Elliot you suck like you are a loser you
sold eight dollars in radishes and let's
break down while you sucked I mean your
Instagram was boring I don't know what
the hell you were thinking
like your radishes look like [ __ ] so
let's start with the biggest thesis
which is no marketing fixes crap product
so there's these are the things that we
would go through no thank you you're
welcome to use this for my class thing
thanks for being on question of the day
you get to ask it my friend you get to
ask the vaynernation any question you
want professor answer the professor's
question yeah in terms of the CEOs what
advice would you give to them to
humanize their brands and then what
platforms what media formats detail yeah
detail examples state of the art 2060 in
August love it
thank you my friend possum you keep
asking questions we'll keep answering
them
you